déjà on a envie de vous demander comment
ça va depuis le décès de votre papa
ça va je dois dire que c'est ça a été
une année très difficile 2022 avec
vraiment été une année parce que c'est
vrai que c'était une mort soudaine c'est
vrai que ça a été ça a été très violent
ouais c'est clair
mais la vie continue et puis je pense
que papa est de tout et je n'avance
comme ça
vous êtes vous êtes fier de sa carrière
je suis fier je vais faire de lui je
suis fier d'être sa fille je suis fière
de porter son nom et
voilà c'était c'était deux personnages
hors du commun
c'est vrai que vous parlez des associez
les deux directs
on a l'impression que moi je suis là
pour parler de mon père
mais c'est cette disparition des deux en
même temps ça six jours d'intervalle ça
a été ça a dû être un choc
parce que c'est vrai que votre papa est
décédé seulement 6 jours après après
Grichka quand vous avez vu que grishai
était parti est-ce que vous avez pas dit
que vous êtes dit
il va pas tenir sur lui
non je pense qu'on y a cru jusqu'à la
dernière seconde et
voilà la vie la vie est ainsi faite
énervé qui refusait qu'il est refusait
tous les vaccins tous les deux le
vaccins contre le covid ou pas du tout
non c'est je respecte son choix c'est ça
et on a respecté son choix toujours et
on le respecte encore et
voilà on l'accompagne
j'ai 33 ans
alors est-ce que vous avez des liens
avec vos autres frères et soeurs ce que
vous avez combien de frères et soeurs
demi alors trois demi-frères un goût
grand frère demi-frère deux petits
frères demi-frères
qui sont les enfants de belle-mère et
une soeur et un frère de même parents
alors c'est vrai qu'on a tous on sait
tous posé des questions sur l'héritage
de des frères Bogdanov c'est vrai que et
Gilles aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on peut
en dire avant qu'on en parle avec Maître
Ludo et Sacha alors la grande question
c'était effectivement quelle héritage
alors on a parlé d'une société et on a
aussi beaucoup parlé du château le
fameux château c'est un château qu'ils
avaient donc acquis tous les deux 280
000 euros il y a très longtemps mais ce
château nécessite des travaux de toiture
très très cher alors on m'avait parlé
avant d'une somme de 4 millions d'euros
mais récemment on m'a dit qu'avec la
hausse des prix etc on serait plutôt
près de 6 millions d'euros ce château
c'est le château
que les frères Bogdanov font à qui en 86
pour un montant d'environ 280000 euros
aujourd'hui il faudrait combien alors il
avait la Société des gens de de
rénovation du coin avait proposé de leur
acheter au BOC d'un offre 800000 euros
il y a un an ou deux mais ils avaient
semble-t-il vous allez confirmer mettre
refusé et aujourd'hui il ne vaut pas
grand chose parce que les travaux de
rénovation coûteraient une fortune
le dossier il était il était comme ça il
est plus comme ça d'abord c'est un
château qui a une histoire il a 1000 ans
pratiquement comme Daniel
il y a l'esprit des bogdanoffres qu'il
faut sauver
ce château il est classé monument
historique
et il a été placé sous la protection
j'allais dire du tribunal de commerce de
Paris et c'est le frère de Sacha va
c'est cela ce qui a été désigné comme
mandataire pour
déposer un dossier au ministère de la
Culture pour qu'il y ait une mise sous
tutelle si je puis dire par l'état où il
est donnant donnant c'est à dire que
l'État s'occupe du château de sa
restauration et en contrepartie et bien
la famille Bogdanov va laisser l'accès à
ce château au public
aux visites aux manifestations au
festival etc etc de toute façon ce que
ce château soit la disposition de
l'intérêt général de la collectivité et
c'est vrai que parler de château
aujourd'hui alors que on se bat dans la
rue pour les retraites à 1000 euros par
mois ça peut-être quelque chose
d'indécent mais en réalité ils veulent
ils veulent l'offrir à la collectivité
parce que ça les vieilles pierres ça les
intéresse pas en tant que tel dire on va
pas s'enrichir avec ça
bien-off qu'il faut sauver et on se dit
que avec l'aide du ministère de la
Culture on va pouvoir y arriver alors
Igor a eu 6 enfants son premier mariage
avec l'actrice Geneviève gras Dimitri
son fils aîné de son sa seconde union
avec lui de Mila Sacha donc
Anna Claria donc néo 91 ainsi que son
fils
26 classes 27 ans voilà de son dernier
mariage avec Amélie de Bourbon par
Alexandre et Constantin donc l'héritage
à se partager entre ces 6 enfants
Grichka n'ayant pas d'enfants il était
logique que ces héritiers soient ces
cinq frères et sœurs ouais parce qu'ils
ont cinq compresseur Laurence Géraldine
Véronique et aussi François d'avant ni
d'une histoire d'amour entre leur mère
et un autre homme c'est son le
demi-frère de Digor et Grichka alors au
moment de leur décès tout le monde a
remarqué que l'un des secrets les mieux
gardés des frères Bogdanov c'est celui
de c'est celui de leur fortune c'est
vrai que on se demandait tous Sacha
voilà qualité en fait qu'est-ce qui
faisait tous les jours pour parce que il
faisait des livres ils faisaient des
trains de vie au quotidien exactement
leur train de vie au quotidien c'est
vrai qu'il y a Igor directement de se
poser la question est-ce qu'il faisait
des folies avec leur argent pas du tout
pas du tout alors vraiment je vais
parler pour mon père mais mon père
jamais jamais dans sa vie j'avais vu
rentrer même dans un magasin pour de
luxe ou quoi que ce soit c'était pas du
tout son truc lui c'était
les deux étaient d'une grande générosité
ils avaient les poches percées l'argent
rentrait ressortait aussitôt
ils ont ils ont jamais eu un saut enfin
c'était toujours voilà il courait après
le voilà voilà mais
[Musique]
mon père il avait pas un matin où il se
levait pas avec une idée en tête et hop
hop non mais attends
tu vas pas revenir alors et puis il
racontait ce qu'il allait faire et tous
ces il était rempli de projets tout le
temps et il faisait rêver il nous
faisait rêver et puis et puis il faisait
rêver les gens je crois c'est vrai que
est-ce qu'ils aient quoi
alors il faisait des projets à droite à
gauche qui qui fonctionnait pas toujours
financer des projets en fait oui ils
étaient oui c'est-à-dire que voilà ils
étaient pas du tout du genre à garder
l'argent pour eux à se remplir les
poches ou voilà c'était donc c'est quoi
l'héritage de des gants Bogdanov en fait
justement il est composé de quoi que du
château il y a quoi d'autre la grande
question c'est est-ce qu'il y a autre
chose que le château à ma connaissance
il y a que le château mais vous allez
nous dire merci
importants pour leur lit valent de 40
000 à euros à 180000 euros
c'est ce qu'on me dit
non c'est bien bien que ça c'est
beaucoup bien que ça c'est ce que je me
disais aussi que j'étais allé
une vingtaine de livres
25 livres mais
aujourd'hui on peut on peut surtout dire
qu'on qu'on vit de nos métiers
certainement pas de de cette succession
mais c'était pas l'idée non plus mais on
a un héritage qui est
qui est bien plus puissant enfin et à
contrario est-ce qu'il y a des dettes
est-ce qu'ils avaient accumulé des
dettes que l'héritage devra rembourser
maître
au niveau fiscal il n'y a pas de
difficulté
il y a ce château où il va falloir
maintenant rapidement avoir l'aide du
ministère de la Culture pour
effectivement que qu'on solidifie tout
ça mais sinon non on a le sentiment que
ce sont des gens qui ont vécu dans les
étoiles qu'ont vécu leur passion et puis
qui sont morts très vite mais ils
habitaient dans le château non non
parce que on avait été fait un truc chez
eux
c'est vrai que voilà c'était une zone un
peu long voilà c'est ça c'est donc
l'appartement qui avait été vendu je
crois il y a quelques vous aviez été
dans l'appartement qui ressemblait un
peu à un château justement où il a
permis
donc il a été vendu je crois qu'il avait
à ma connaissance
la maison la maison ça fait ça fait un
moment oui c'est ça qu'elle a été vendue
oui ça ne leur appartenait plus Cyril
c'est ça d'accord
Sacha c'est c'est vrai que la fille de
d'Igor Bogdanoff est-ce que les gens
vous devez vous poser plein de questions
sur votre père parce que c'est vrai que
c'est ça reste un des mystères
incroyable c'est vrai que il gore voilà
on sait tous demander voilà s'il venait
de la même planète que nous c'est vrai
que voilà
vraiment même vous vous compreniez pas
votre père parfois ah mais oui
complètement oui c'est ça qui était
génial
j'ai été élevé par un père qui vivait
dans les étoiles clairement ouais
vraiment
[Musique]
tout le temps dans un autre monde mais
en même temps
très très dans son instant présent et ça
ça c'est précieux je trouve parce que
sur diplômé quand même bien sûr
tous les deux donc là vous Sacha si vous
avez des questions posées n'hésitez pas
vous en fait parce que c'est vrai que
tout le monde s'imaginait je vous dis
parce que c'était important de le dire
tout le monde s'imaginait que les
Bogdanov avait une fortune incroyable et
c'est vrai que à chaque fois que les
gens passent à la télé qui font une
carrière on a l'impression qu'on croit
que ils sont voilà je pense que c'est le
beau c'est beaucoup ces questions qui
reviennent c'est ça mais en fait ils
vous ont vous êtes reparti de zéro
effectivement cette émission de
télévision derrière
vous avez rien vous avez par le nom et
l'héritage de de ce qui vous ont un peu
de ce qui vous a appris votre papa vous
a rien laissé en fait je sais pas si on
peut dire qu'on est reparti de zéro est
parti comme ça enfin comme tout le monde
quoi c'est ça oui Benjamin juste le
catalogue Temps X des missions qui à
partir de au frère de rien c'est
d'accord
c'était des personnages hors du commun
qui étaient souvent caricaturés parfois
moqués alors parfois avec beaucoup de
bienveillance parfois un peu moins
est-ce que ça vous a touché vous quand
vous étiez plus jeune je pense qu'on est
on est toujours touché surtout si ça
touche à l'image de du paternel
après
eux ils étaient ils étaient au dessus
de ça pas dans le sens négatif du terme
mais
est-ce que
ils en ont souffert de ça non c'est vrai
ils en ont pas souffert
[Musique]
savait trouver le drôle dans chaque
situation c'est ça tout était
tout était
tout était matière à rire rien n'était
un problème c'était jamais de problème
c'est facile c'est pas grave c'est
facile d'être la fille du corbeau
est-ce qu'on vous disait
[Musique]
ça m'a forgé
des moments de tension parce qu'il y a
eu trop de moquerie à l'école ou pas du
tout non jamais vous laissiez passer les
gens étaient toujours bienveillants il y
a pas de enfin
ils avaient ce côté très sympathique qui
faisait aussi que même si on pouvait les
même si on pouvait parfois négatif moi
j'ai pas forcément à l'école
non pas forcément
de temps en temps mais après c'était
c'était il était très souvent en retard
de toute façon ah oui c'est vrai oui
parce qu'il était pas dans le même temps
que vous il était temps
donc oui maintenant
oui on sait parfois que dans les
familles recomposées ça peut être un peu
compliqué quand il y a des demi-frères
des demi-sœurs des succession et vous
tout se passe bien
moi j'adore mes petits frères j'adore
mon grand frère tout le monde s'aime
beaucoup
le fait pour reparler de l'héritage le
fait qui est 11 héritiers au total je
crois mettre est-ce que ça a compliqué
ou pas du tout est-ce que vraiment tout
le monde est en osmose est-ce qu'il y a
une complexité non tout le monde en ne
se passe parce que chacun va décider on
sent la mal conscience s'ils acceptent
ou ils acceptent pas la succession ah ça
c'est pas encore décidé ça c'est pas
encore décidé chacun sa réflexion ce qui
est sûr c'est que Sacha Anna et ben
c'est cela qui veulent s'emparer du de
j'allais dire de l'esprit des Bogdanov
veulent conserver le château et se
battre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je suis là et on a trouvé la solution
les autres se sentent au moins concernés
voilà
les scientifiques
se sont un petit peu attaqués à eux
puisqu'ils allaient très très loin dans
leur réflexion et dans leur pensée y
compris le lavant Big Bang et ainsi de
suite donc là évidemment ils ont dû
prendre quelques quelques coups de la
part de je dirais pas de confrères mais
enfin de scientifiques qui disait bon
ce sont des hurluberlues quoi donc
qu'est-ce que ça vous avez souffert de
de ça j'imagine et peut-être eux aussi
j'ai pas le souvenir qui a eu une de tel
il y a eu la discussion il y a eu de la
contestation mais j'ai pas le souvenir
que dans les émissions scientifiques où
ils étaient invités que il n'est pas été
traité sur la même plan l'égalité qui
est scientifique je pense qu'ils étaient
effectivement très respectés de ce côté
là à mon sens donc
vous êtes vous-même dans le domaine
artistique aujourd'hui vous chantez vous
fait plein de choses mais on a la
sensation vous êtes discrète vous mettez
plutôt en retrait est-ce que c'est en
voyant la vie de votre père et de son
frère que vous êtes dit peut-être que la
notoriété rend la vie compliquée comme
on l'entend parfois est-ce que c'est
difficile à vivre
bah oui c'est pas vraiment enfin c'est
c'est pas en voyant la vie de mon père
c'est c'est
un rythme de vie que je préfère un choix
simplement c'est un choix ouais de bah
en fait de d'exercer ma passion après si
les choses enfin je sais pas c'est une
question moi pareil là je suis dans
l'instant présent je veux dire pour
l'instant je suis heureuse comme ça je
me sens épanouie donc voilà j'ai pas
j'ai pas envie d'être d'être sur le
devant de la scène particulièrement je
fais ce que j'aime je chante et c'est
bon pour moi pour prolonger la question
de Guillaume est-ce qu'à un moment ça
vous a effleuré de le fait de prendre un
pseudo de pas être la fille de Bogdanov
justement pour exister en tant
qu'artiste par vous même et qu'on vous
ramène pas tout le temps à votre père
tout à fait c'est ce qui s'est passé je
me suis j'ai commencé en m'appelant
Sacha simplement tout simplement on a
beaucoup parlé de leur évolution
physique et ce que vous ça vous a choqué
par rapport à votre papa parce qu'on
arrive un peu moqué et ils ont beaucoup
changé en 15 ans ils ont vraiment changé
de physique quoi
et une grande question sur est-ce que ça
a été refait ou pas voilà pose la
question que tout le monde y pense on y
va
demain c'est sûr
et ça leur appartient et alors là ça je
vais leur laisser je
dirais-je à ce point
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non
je sais pas je pense qu'on en a assez
parlé dans la presse pour que je me pose
pas spécialement de questions c'était
leur mystère et je le respecte et enfin
voilà moi je je
vous disais pas tout
il nous disait pas tout et puis j'avais
l'heure leur jardin secret et puis leur
intimité et je pense qu'on n'est pas
obligé de tous dire dans les dans les
familles même si déjà
de faire un film sur la vie de votre
père de votre oncle
sur ces derniers mystère
par contre
c'est un projet de fondation fondation
Igor et Grichka qui va j'espère se
trouver dans le château et qui a pour
but effectivement de faire partager aux
jeunes la passion de l'univers de
l'origine de l'univers et de faire en
sorte que on puisse effectivement les
amener à être intéressés à cela ça c'est
un grand projet des trois alors outre le
fait que vous êtes absolument charmante
et lumineuse et qu'on a beaucoup de
plaisir à vous à vous à vous rencontrer
moi je voulais savoir pourquoi vous
acceptez de venir ce soir en fait vous
avez besoin de la médiatisation par
rapport à votre ben non je vais vous
dire tout de suite
je vais vous le dire très simplement mon
père il aime beaucoup c'est vrai
réciproquement et on a été sollicité
beaucoup pour pour apparaître à l'image
et c'est ça vous avez en fait vous avez
pensé que si vous aviez des choses à
dire c'était ici qu'il fallait le dire
parce que voilà par rapport au lien
c'est vraiment vous savez que il y a un
truc moi quand j'avais à chaque fois que
je fais une émission que je lançais une
nouvelle émission les premiers que j'ai
invités c'était Igor et quelqu'un ils
m'ont toujours porter bonheur je les ai
toujours invités dans toutes mes
émissions et à chaque fois ils m'ont
porté bonheur et c'était vraiment je
voulais absolument refaire ton X et
qu'on avait même fait un pilote
il faut que tu viennes on devait on
devait le relancer on avait fait un
pilote et c'est vrai que je les ai
toujours eu toujours toujours à chaque
fois il m'a envoyé des petits SMS et
tous les je vous jure que c'est vrai il
y a pas une semaine qui passait sans que
l'un ou l'autre m'envoie un sms pour
dire Cyril on a une idée à chaque fois
il avait une idée différente à chaque
fois il venait me voir et venez me voir
au bureau il me disait bon bah on veut
faire si on va faire ça et c'est vrai
que voilà j'ai j'ai une tendresse pour
eux parce que c'est des mecs voilà que
j'aime et que j'aimerais toujours est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter ce
soir à Sacha
[Musique]
les Bogdanov continuent de vivre ils
sont plus là physiquement mais il
continue par les projets
non pas par les pierres mais par l'idée
de la Fondation
pédagogique de d'apporter en fait ils
arrivaient à faire comprendre des choses
tellement compliquées
exactement
dans la rue mais tu comprends tu
comprends si on a cette Marguerite qui a
mais il pouvait partir dans la rue avec
n'importe qui et lui parler de rat
dessus bras dessous et il a jamais
refusé à personne
un entretien ou une photo ou je sais pas
c'était c'était deux personnages
généreux et qui avaient qui avait voilà
qui avait à coeur de partager les choses
et donc je pense que ce château
d'esniaque il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
vivent comme ça en fait dans le partage
et puis il a besoin de recevoir d'avoir
l'énergie des gens de vivre à travers à
travers la science à travers la
littérature parce que ils étaient très
littéraires et surtout Igor très très
littéraire donc si on peut créer ce pôle
culturel
là-bas dans ce lieu qui va avoir bientôt
1000 ans et qui est juste
un lieu féerique et magique bah voilà ce
serait ce serait ce serait moi